really no this is very difficult that
I've tried to teach this over the years
it has a lot to do with senator
connection meaning that the extremities
of your body are being interrelated
through your core that takes
coordination and it tastes strength and
it also takes emotional fortitude
because we're going to put it in places
where your mind is going to go into a
self-defense mode and it's going to go
your spirits going to go egocentric
you're going to lose an external
pressurizing and the two extremities
will stop relating to each other because
your Center will deflate okay so you
gotta hang in there we're gonna go slow
but you have to do your basket even as
I've seen through the decade slope so
the technique we're going to do is I
have my EQ all right got the idea okay
so first we want to get you into the
ballpark with you Kimmy okay so if we
look as I am attacking relax as I am
attacking stop my attack is forwarded
through do you understand okay so when
he moves my limb he's moving the distal
end of my lover it was not going to be
the case that my body's gonna go like
that not at full speed just watch a
motorcycle crash the body will keep
going that way and the limbs will go
another way you understand so usually in
a lot of Aikido we we fake that we we he
goes and we like that know only slow so
we want to go fast
eventually so I have to get used to the
idea that he blew the distal and that's
what happens do you understand
so this is drill one right I'm going to
push in and I keep walking
you gonna lift my balance
let yourself keep going in up out okay
so I've already seen acts of
disengagement and that always leads to
disconnection okay what's the connection
that relationship between the
extremities of my body through the
center of my box okay so as I come in
you see that step right there that's the
disengagement
you didn't keep going in we see this a
lot all the time okay so so someone's
gonna do quick good tug - right and give
you the do put in the edge alright and
the Angus that's the disengagement what
that you know I thought trying to rest
on one and I feel just please I don't
have control of that person okay so if
you if you feel the guy and he's already
disengaging I'm going to eat you yeah so
we need to train ourselves for eco we
have to do the energy print as you get
sore iki ohm and we're just doing this
drill so I'll go slow and I will keep
walking in it until he takes my balance
I will not go that's about all I'm gonna
walk it you see keep walking in
he takes my back not like this
disengagement now I'm not working my
Center long boom he's pushing on my
center
they tried again more discipline okay so
here I have a tatami this is the center
of the mat only because I have these two
sides and these two sides
if I didn't have the extremities
I cannot have Center if that if these
two lines went on ad infinitum I would
not be able to have them Center assumes
that there are two extremities and they
are in relationship to each other as
well as the center okay so when did I
come into the technique you'll see that
my head and foot get like clock hands
when I pull my Center out of the
technique because it goes the other way
my head and my feet are not in
relationship they're disconnected if I
just keep going in with my Center keeps
going in is please pull only one leg
will be able to come up you can't go
like this this is gonna feel very
awkward to your body the outside light
will be the three leg just keep keep
walking and you'll see it's gonna be the
outside leg that comes up because of how
the crossbar will check
don't pull your Center out of the
technique experience the head and sweat
relationship okay try forgetting to eat
go so this is why we're going to pretend
that the guys that choo-choo train dis
all these tracks you don't have to act
like the Train he could just walk ass
and I'm gonna go out and back it so it's
my shape in relationship to his line of
attack generates a triangulation he
comes forward I step out and right back
in behind
out in
oh okay let's try it try it when she's
near right we're gonna combine this
Boudreaux because I'm doing this
triangulation I'm actually going to add
a rotation to what's happening into his
center
okay so he comes in and I go out and
okay got it
so I'll show you Kimmy because I have to
wait let's get back with me I have to
maintain that
senator connection by maintaining a
relationship between the two extremities
so I go in so I can't go and he goes and
we'll stay here and you'll see I don't
break connection leave the connection
that connection at this pace will
manifest itself with my foot at least
glue level if it's below glute level you
broke connection with your head so out
very much like warrior poses in yoga
okay let's try that
let me tell all that drug if you need
more absorption you can take the
absorption but you're going to go out to
get you to turn the other way so if we
do the very first drill he comes in and
you see how it does that to his body
stay there as best you can
I'm not what I'm going to do is turn it
and you see how the game's up there you
guys see that we're just doing that in
motion so warm
Oh
this is the first step of that kind of
theft this fight will go out we start
liking you
let's have a spike to note here what's
up forecast people so wherever I I'm
touching him I should feel my feet and
his feet so no matter what or whatever
I'm touching him so that I can't affect
his math okay whenever I'm touching I
should go through that same organization
from his extremities through this Center
to the other extremity you see that when
I find the other extremity then I know I
will always have his his center whatever
I'm doing do you guys got that next
thing so what I take you Kimmy I'm doing
the same thing so here I'm touching him
I have to be able to feel his feet and
that is going to allow me to not have oh
let go of me did not I have one foot and
I do a balance trick I have three feet
there's three feet all right I'm gonna
hang out here all day because I have a
better stance now than when I stand on
my own I am feeling his feet through
what he's touching you guys see that and
he's feeling my foot through what he's
touching and both of us are cutting
through our Center to that I'm not
leaning on him I'm just relating to him
okay so let's try and do that as you can
go another side note we don't want to
eat you to be an armbar can't control
someone by controlling their limb it's
low percentage but to control their body
thinking wrong think
till someone's body by gravity so we
don't want to do that also like always
we don't want to be on this stuff in
this linear XY axis world where he's at
12 on at 6 and then I go to 12 and maybe
I work on the diagonals that that's not
very sophisticated either ok so if we
get him in the last body posture he's
like this and we have again generated
that body posture that allows me to
affect his balance right so his head is
down and when I push this hip and rotate
him he will fall so you do your best
let go this side I'm going to have this
head go this way and his hip go over
that way and then he loses the mountain
see that if we do it again and you're
going to be very athletic I'm going to
just push it that way and I don't want
you to follow when she got off if you
read everything you keep your balance
see that okay and you know what you do
whatever it takes to keep development
okay so this is always what we you get a
bit of diagonal the head goes one way
and the hip will go along the way in the
garbage ball okay so as they go to this
technique then I don't want to go like
this straight you see it's not going on
the third note I want to do what looks
obvious
so my pattern is in I'm sorry out in but
we're going to go that way
boom here
and in my drill it should end up with
his elbow right in my store lines find
life right underneath me
[Music]
as he's falling I controlling this elbow
it doesn't take any energy just have to
do it as he swallowed if you wait
there'll be a lot of external energy
from the centripetal energy of the
spiral so our drill is down and it ends
up right under me that tells me I had
weight over his elbow okay let's try
that drill
the assumption is is you know how to
ensure you understand ankle angle knee
angle foot alignment mid-foot way okay
so if you're not entering correctly you
won't have the horse factors for an
entry incorrect
go back and watch that young video of
the lower Yangtze okay
all right so you saw that I was doing it
with a finger so clearly though I'm not
using the arm to take him down okay
so we're gonna check for that so we need
to come to the ground that we found
about his wrist the other hand will do
the elbow and Arnaud will step it so I'm
not fighting the arrow his arm I'm
fighting the Archer in his body okay so
I'm going to really focus on that
triangulation and get my Cushing into
this technique
I am displacing his base we can't occupy
the same space do you understand that so
when I'm actually controlling his arm
I'm not actually controlling his arm
following his arm down I'm not taking
him down he's falling down so we want to
check for falling down okay if they roll
out that's fine because I don't have the
arms so that's cool okay if they don't
and they just fall them in a face that's
cool - it doesn't matter
okay so we go and I'm here all men on it
this place is base angle this track how
many mistakes you're not doing you know
you don't have your clothes she in there
you don't have the figure eight pattern
okay so you want like this and you're
going 12 six then you go straight and
you missed his hips you're in the armpit
area sometimes you go well I went a
little that way about in the wrist
you got to get underneath you got to get
like you're going to do this like not do
it okay so say good common mistake is
you closed it off and now you try to go
in there is no in the tube collapsed on
you your bad body surfer okay so time it
boom it time it in
hey Charlie German x2 common mistakes
easier just pushing them here I'm not
using the technique I'm just using that
triangulation you can play with how much
let's just do the one that comes in or
just playing with that I don't need that
you see I'm not using that just displace
me in this space so I just need a tiny
turn that's it I got boom that's it
don't use the arm Sega mistake is
related to that it really to the armpit
is you're not going enough you're not
trying to go anything enough okay so
take more nor stop so north south and
let's let's balls arm no boom let go the
arm this attack nice base bold lickable
the arm so we'll stop here tonight we're
not going to get to them to begin okay
but let's combine the two drills with
the next step okay so he's already
falling right and I just stay up with
that elbow mount see that I'm not gonna
put it on the ground this time I'm gonna
move to keep my Center over the elbow as
it's falling I'm not taking it down I
don't have my Center over it so I'm
heavy I have it over so he can't get up
okay and I'm just staying up with it so
I'm gonna move like the takedown this
year and I just moved in with that you
see how I'm doing that so my flip
manoeuvres are going to be out it
to bring this around again so to take
these four warm brown blue end around
again
here's where I end my feet are under me
for today feet under me elbow under me
some orientation cues when you come
around boom you see his face
if I put this underneath my foot is
should be in alignment with his face
okay steak update about kicking this
time stay over the elbow keep moving to
stay with it
yeah I don't I'm not using the arm to
take her down this this position that
she's falling so I just stand up with
this if you use the arm just keep take
her down your base is going to have to
be is being pinned so you leave it there
and you're behind it now okay you're
always pushing it you're behind it now
so she's being taken down by this she's
being taken down by that own you see you
have all your strikes and everything
available
you take your carry you got that nicely
guys be alive there you go just stay up
with it don't use it to be taking her
down okay go stay up with it not ahead
of it you're going
in and round so it's gonna call around
you you're gonna surround you she's not
throwing around you
you coming in right your head is going
to go around you see not pushing you
away not doing that you're going to go
around then I come this so the first
move is here second move is here okay
hey not too in the same direction hey
hey go to be under you
you know to eat you don't do bicho
Yuriko socks do you Joe just do the
drill
I'll do the drill play with the drill
okay let's go hi hi art there you gotta
wait I must be pushing him hey this legs
pushing on me batter up
don't take the last step don't put the
hand down in out if you take this step
ouch
now that has not by you you see that but
if you take this step by your other foot
oh oh that's so weird
you see that and now you step out and
bring you on the foot over it
oh that's odd okay let's go
bring your feet by each other in by each
other then how a feet together yay
perfect good by each other to each other
by each other to each other
whoops got out from under you by each
other to each other your feet are like
this and unless you walked in like that
then I don't want to see them okay
so kid by each other to each other okay
by each other to each other
don't put the hand down don't put the
hand down are you sure I'm pretty sure
each other to each other we have to
finish
[Music]
Oh